pas idéal j'attends enfin son journal
pour les nouvelles j'espère qu'elles
seront sociaux tels voyages grands
reportages tenace et benzema sur
qu'outil des ptic romera eu de très
grosses haute
l'autre petit écho de la forêt
trouverait il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le tue des cours de
l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons cherté des femmes quelles
sont les nouvelles d'aujourd'hui tube
puis pour le pigeon prend sa retraite
il faut bien dire que notre ami n'est
plus un pigeonneau alors pipeau ça va
mieux
mon fils tu m'as les reins fort bouffe
ta convalescence tiens ça fait bobo va
pouvoir reprendre son travail
bof tous ces plaisirs qui est bof
pourquoi bof est prêt pour vivre
j'ai été le cas pour mademoiselle de la
citrouille bouffe tu vas boire et 8
porter n'existe pas il
il battait les pendre bouffe négatif les
potes tu es pris de décision laquelle je
prends ma retraite quoi oui j'ai plus
l'offre de jouer les pigeons voyageurs
flashes la place aux jeunes mais comme
allons nous faire pour avoir des
nouvelles de magma c'est la psychose de
fall bord les habits je suis au pij au
tchad leurs sources
guillaume edwards suivez-moi y pendant
plusieurs jours pipeau resteront fermés
avec les frères k stores dans leurs
ateliers
je me demande ce qui peut bien fabriqué
sur peut-être aux terminaux byword
tribunaux pipon après peut-être un
métier impossible
il a pris sa retraite il se bat
attention fragile et qu'est ce que vous
faites vous voulez avant des nouvelles
de ma besoin de la cigogne et l'eau
demain matin celui des moyens humains si
c'est toi p pas furent battus toit et
des mini 1012 massette et casquette
c'est une caisse que d'employer des
postes parce que nous avons des bureaux
de poste mme athéna tous pourvus le
grito mais sa vie
ça mais nous avons de l'eau des postes
tout le petit monde de la forêt fut très
étonné beaulieu c'est pour parce que
j'ai pris ma retraite que je devrais
vous privés de courrier
thanou coûts et notre courrier beaucoup
revu alors nous allons l'attendre
lagathu pourquoi ce que je fais c'est
l'heure de burgos coûte une heure plus
tard c'est employait passé ils prennent
leurs aises s'est ouvert à qui le tour
et à voir à part dont zip
j'étais là la première nomme moi pas du
tout le monde sera servi
c'est une carte pour mont crosin de
bretagne c'est parti et voici pour la
tante de sabra mais c'est une carte à
jouer
oui battante elle avant jouer à la
volante wasquehal pourra mieux su et de
géographie
oui moi vouloir kellou amis sachent où
j'ai su que you'll pas des nouvelles et
la triche est cigognes tous deux pigeons
j'oubliais vous une carte tenu à bien
gérer vous allez c'est pas pour doser
pompe et pau oui
ouais gros serpent c'est vrai pipeau mon
cher pipeau je m'ennuie de vous revenez
moi vite seuil et adèle de la cigogne
vous avez entendu et s'ennuient
demoiselle est oui sans moi et les voir
ta gueule
yabon faire court oui je prends des
vacances
pourquoi parce que je vais progresser ce
topo voix d'elles qui pensent plus qu'à
moi alors ni peinture et parle pour le
venice
je veux maintenant très courts yeux je
déposerai aux passants ils ont tu ne
prends plus tard très négatif qu'est ce
que vous voulez ouais je la pige en
voyageur dans l'âme
salut la compagnie et oui cher téléphone
puis poids raison on n'échappe pas à sa
nature un bientôt cher téléphone pour
une prochaine édition du petit écho de
la vraie